Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Alas, now o'er the civilised world there hangs a gloom For brave General Gordon that was killed in Khartoum He was a Christian hero and a soldier of the cross And to England his death will be a very great loss He was very cool in temper, generous and brave, the friend of the poor, the sick and the slave. And many a poor boy he did educate and laboured hard to do so early
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。如果你想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们广受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。唉，如今整个文明世界笼罩着一片阴霾，为了在喀土穆牺牲的勇敢的戈登将军他是一位基督教英雄和十字架的战士，他的死对英格兰将是巨大的损失他性格极其冷静、慷慨而勇敢，是穷人、病人以及奴隶的朋友。他教育了许多可怜的男孩，并为此日夜辛勤劳作
and late. The inimitable poetic style of friend of the show William McGonagall, whose great masterpiece on the disaster of the the Tay Bridge we've already featured on The Restless History in our 12 Days of Christmas episode and Dominic the death of General Gordon the archetypal Victorian hero at Khartoum in Sudan on the 26th of January 1885 was seen as a disaster fit to rank with the Tay Bridge disaster wasn't it? Oh a far greater disaster than the Tay Bridge disaster Tom. The death of Gordon at Khartoum is one of the absolute emblematic moments of the Victorian era. It's an extraordinary shock to Victorian Britain. It's one of the Victorian era. It's an extraordinary shock to Victorian Britain. It's one of the great media events of the Victorian age.
及至深夜。这正是本节目老朋友威廉·麦格哥纳格尔（William McGonagall）那无可模仿的诗歌风格。我们之前在《圣诞节的12天》节目中，已经在《历史的余烬》里介绍过他关于泰伊桥灾难的伟大杰作。多米尼克，1885年1月26日，喀土穆的维多利亚时代原型英雄戈登将军在苏丹喀土穆身亡，这被视为一场堪与泰伊桥灾难相提并论的惨剧，不是吗？哦，汤姆，这比泰伊桥灾难要惨烈得多。戈登在喀土穆的死是维多利亚时代最具代表性的绝对时刻之一。这对维多利亚时代的英国来说是一个非同寻常的震撼。它是维多利亚时代的伟大媒体事件之一。
And General Gordon is one of the absolute kind of emblematic martyrs of the British Empire. One of the most famous men in the world, I would say, at the point that he died. So fascinating you say that because we've got a question from Stefan Jensen, another friend of the show show who's always popping up with his questions i think he's been in abeyance recently but he's back and he says who on earth is general charles george gordon what a thing to say stephan what a thing to say well but i mean i i'll be honest i mean i have a
戈登将军可以说是大英帝国绝对具有象征意义的殉道者之一。我想说，在他去世时，他是世界上最著名的人物之一。你这么说太引人入胜了，因为我们收到了来自斯特凡·延森（Stefan Jensen）的问题。这也是我们的老朋友，总是带着问题出现。我想他最近一段时间比较沉寂，但现在他又回来了。他问：“查尔斯·乔治·戈登将军到底是谁？”斯特凡，你居然会这么说！怎么能说出这样的话呢？不过，说实话……
kind of vague sense of him standing at the top of some steps with people with spears getting ready to spit in the kind of famous archetypal image. But apart from that, I didn't really know a huge amount about him. But having. Well, basically, this week I've gone down General Gordon shape rabbit hole. I mean, they're really, really it is a brilliant topic. And one of the things that is brilliant about Gordon is precisely what has happened to his subsequent reputation. So someone who was so famous is now not a name to play with by and large, but also Victorian hero, the archetype of a Christian Victorian hero,
我有一种模模糊糊的印象，觉得他站在某处台阶的顶端，周围是一群拿着长矛、准备向他吐口水的暴民——那是那张著名的标志性照片。除此之外，我对他其实并不太了解。但是……嗯，基本上，这周我掉进了“戈登将军”的研究兔子洞里。我的意思是，这真的是一个非常、非常精彩的主题。关于戈登，最妙的一点恰恰在于他后来的声誉发生了怎样的变化。曾经如此著名的一个人物，现在基本上已经变成了一个不宜提起的名字；但他同时也是维多利亚时代的英雄，一个基督教维多利亚时代英雄的原型，
but then subsequently gets kind of skewered by Lytton Strachey in his famous, kind of famously feline book volume of biographies of eminent Victorians. So what is it? It's Dr. Arnold Florence Nightingale and Cardinal Newman. One of the Cardinals. Yeah. So the question of how we're to understand Gordon, I mean, it kind of bleeds into the broader topic of how are we to understand the British Empire? All those, I mean, very kind of hot button issue.
然而后来，他在莱顿·斯特奇（Lytton Strachey）那本著名的、充满尖刻风格的传记文集《维多利亚时代名人传》（Eminent Victorians）中被无情地剖析了。里面写了谁？阿诺德博士、弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔和纽曼枢机主教。其中一位枢机主教。是的。所以，我们该如何理解戈登这个问题，其实也延伸到了我们该如何理解大英帝国这个更广泛的主题？所有这些，都是非常敏感的话题。
Yeah. And it kind of also feeds into the broader theme, which is the question of how reputations over the course of history have evolved. How some people go up, some people go do down and we are going to be talking about that live are we not oh yeah that's a very nice link tom we're doing a live show aren't we about reputations for rest is history club members now maybe not everybody listening to this will know about the rest is history club i may have some new listeners. Yeah, but we may have new listeners, Tom, who are attracted by the subject of General Gordon. Yes, we will. And, you know, we can open up to them the great vista of the Rest Is History Club.
是的。这也顺应了一个更广泛的主题，那就是：在历史的长河中，人们的声誉是如何演变的。为什么有些人名声上升，有些人名声下降？我们将会现场讨论这个话题，对吧？哦，对，这衔接得太棒了，汤姆！我们确实要为“历史的余烬”俱乐部会员举办一场关于声誉的现场秀，对吧？现在，收听这期节目的可能并非所有人、所有新听众都知道“历史的余烬”俱乐部。是的，但汤姆，我们可能会有一些被戈登将军这个主题吸引来的新听众。是的，会的。而且，你知道的，我们可以向他们展现“历史的余烬”俱乐部的广阔前景。
So this is a club that you sign up to. Costs next to nothing, I would say. Next to nothing. Restishistorypod.com. And you get basically all the episodes without adverts. You get access to archive without adverts. You get – you can run this splendid thing called the Discord chat
这是一个你可以注册加入的俱乐部。我可以说，费用几乎为零。几乎等于没有。Restishistorypod.com。基本上，你所有的节目都没有广告，还能无广告地访问档案馆。你可以——你可以使用这个名为Discord聊天的绝妙工具，
where people chat about history. You get live streams with us and all kinds of goodies. I can't remember what the other goodies are, but I seem to remember they're absolutely tremendous. Well, the particular goody that we're talking about in this context is a live event on the question of reputation in history. That's this Wednesday, the 26th of January at eight o'clock London time. And I'll tell you something else that you get if you become a club member, is that if you bump into me, as two people did this morning at a conference,
大家可以在那里畅谈历史。你可以观看我们的直播以及各种各样的好东西。我不记得还有什么其他好东西了，但我依稀记得它们绝对非常棒。嗯，我们在这种情况下讨论的特定好福利，是一场关于历史人物声誉问题的现场活动。就在本周三，1月26日伦敦时间八点。我还要告诉你成为俱乐部会员能得到的另一件事，那就是如果你像今天早上在会议上有两个人那样偶遇我，
and you are club members, you get a shout-out. So I'm going to give a shout-out to James Farrow, who is a friend of the show, club member, and Ernie Wakeford, who is 13. Oh, that's nice. And a club member. So that's splendid, isn't it? Was this a hedgehog-saving conference? And Stonehenge time opposing.
并且你们是俱乐部会员，你就会得到一次点名致意。所以我要向詹姆斯·法罗（James Farrow）致以谢意，他是本节目的朋友、俱乐部会员；还有埃尼·韦克福德（Ernie Wakeford），他今年13岁。哦，那太好了。也是俱乐部会员。这太棒了，对吧？这是一场拯救刺猬的会议吗？而且还伴随着巨石阵的时间反对。
Oh, very good. All your causes wrapped into one. Absolutely. So we should get back to General Gordon. Yes. Okay. So Stefan's question, who on earth is General Charles George Gordon? Dominic, do you want to give a kind of very brief resume of his career?
哦，太棒了。你所有的事业都合而为一了。完全是这样。所以我们应该回到戈登将军的话题上来。是的。好吧。斯特凡的问题是：“查尔斯·乔治·戈登将军到底是谁？”多米尼克，你想不想对他的职业生涯做一个非常简短的概述？
Golly, well, if you were giving a very brief resume, you would say this. Just a very brief one he's born in 1833 he dies in 1885 uh gordon is the in some ways for the british the ultimate imperial hero he um sees action in this huge range of extraordinary places in the crimean war in china he's present at the burning of the summer palace by brit's present at the burning of the Summer Palace by British troops at the end of the Second Opium War. He then commands a small kind of almost paramilitary unit called the Ever Victorious Army in China fighting against the Taiping Rebellion, which is this kind of this massive and incredibly
天哪，好吧，如果要给出一个非常简短的概述，你会这么说：仅仅是非常简短的一个，他生于1833年，死于1885年。在某种程度上，戈登对英国人来说是终极的帝国英雄。他在许多非凡的地方参与过战斗：克里米亚战争、中国——第二次鸦片战争末期，英国军队火烧圆明园时他在场；英国军队火烧圆明园时他在场。随后，他在中国指挥了一支几乎带有准军事性质的小部队，名为“常胜军”，抗击太平天国起义。这是一场规模庞大、极其惨烈的战争，
kind of bloody war involving a kind of heavenly cult, which Gordon helps to defeat. He goes to the Balkans. He goes to the Sudan. Then he has lots of other kind of adventures. And then he ends up going back to the Sudan in 1884. The Sudan is wracked with war and rebellion. And with this kind of jihadi group
其中涉及某种天国邪教，戈登协助击败了他们。他去过巴尔干半岛。他去过苏丹。然后他还有过许多其他各种各样的冒险。接着，在1884年，他再次返回苏丹。当时的苏丹正饱受战争与叛乱的蹂躏，并面对着一种类似圣战的集团，
led by a fellow called the Mahdi, who thinks he's kind of a prophet, a chosen one, paving the way for the advent of, I think it's the advent of Jesus, is it, Tom? It is, yeah. The return of Jesus. And Gordon ends up trapped in Khartoum,
该集团由一个自称为先知、天选之人的家伙领导，名叫马赫迪。他为耶稣的降临铺平了道路——我想是耶稣的降临吧，汤姆？是的，确实如此。即耶稣的归来。最后，戈登被困在了喀土穆，
in the capital of the Sudan, with the eyes of the world on him, and the Mahdi's army closing in. The British are desperate, finally, to rescue him, but do they get there in time? Well, we shouldn't give the end away, but basically there's a very dramatic denouement. And then after the story ends,
也就是苏丹的首都，全世界的目光都聚焦在他身上，而马赫迪的军队正步步逼近。英国人终于拼命想要去营救他，但他们能及时赶到吗？好吧，我们不应该剧透结局，但基本上有一个非常戏剧性的结局。然后故事结束后，
Gordon becomes the story ends Gordon becomes the and I don't think icon is the wrong word I think icon is absolutely the right word because he's a real the key thing about Gordon apart from all this amazing Imperial adventure story is he's a religious figure he sees himself as a religious figure he his apps
戈登成为了……故事结束后，戈登成为了……我觉得用“偶像”这个词并没有错。我认为“偶像”绝对是恰如其分的词，因为除了所有这些惊人的帝国冒险故事之外，最关键的一点在于：他是一个宗教人物。他将自己视为一个宗教人物。他每时每刻、
you know he he thinks about religion every minute of every day and the religious side of him is has fascinated people ever since yeah so that second verse by mcgonigal it highlights the the ambivalences in his life and in his reputation so he was very cool in temper generous and brave the friend of the of the poor, the sick and the slave. And a key part of what he's doing in the Sudan is that he is fighting slavery. He is trying to abolish the slave trade. And this is something that he comes across very early in his career because he gets seconded to Armenia, which is on the kind of frontiers of the Ottoman Empire. And he sees there for himself the slave trading, the obtaining of slaves from Armenia that the Ottomans are doing,
每天每分钟都在思考宗教，他身上的宗教一面自此之后一直让人着迷。是的，所以麦格哥纳格尔的第二节诗，突显了他生平及其声誉中的矛盾之处：他性格冷静、慷慨而勇敢，是穷人、病人以及奴隶的朋友。他在苏丹所做事情的一个关键部分，就是他在打击奴隶制。他试图废除奴隶贸易。这是他职业生涯很早就接触到的事情，因为他被借调到亚美尼亚，那里处于奥斯曼帝国的边境。他在那里亲眼目睹了奴隶贸易，看到了奥斯曼人从亚美尼亚获取奴隶、
getting slaves for Constantinople. And so that is a theme that runs throughout his life. And it's part of what's going on when he goes back to Khartoum. So he is kind of emblematically a figure who fights the slave trade. He is a liberal. He's the ultimate liberal imperialist. And actually, the funny thing about him is as imperial heroes go, you were saying about his reputation dipping. But he's one of the, in some ways, I would say one of the least likely to be cast.
为君士坦丁堡搜罗奴隶的行为。所以，这是贯穿他一生的一条主线。这也是他重返喀土穆时正在做的事情的一部分。因此，他象征性地成为了一个打击奴隶贸易的人物。他是一个自由主义者。他是终极的自由主义帝国主义者。实际上，关于他有趣的一点是，作为帝国英雄，你刚才提到他的声誉有所下降。但在某种程度上，我认为他是最不可能被抛弃的人之一。
Absolutely. And I think we will come to this. But there is then the second, the other last three or four lines and many a poor boy he did educate and labored hard to do so early and late and this is what listen strachey fixes on in his biography it's what richard davenport hines in um a recent biography of him but kind of very short biographical sketch, describes him as a creep. Gordon never marries. He is notoriously, he gets kind of,
绝对如此。我想我们待会儿会谈到这一点。但随后还有第二段、最后三四行：“他教育了许多可贫苦的男孩，并为此日夜辛勤劳作。”这就是莱顿·斯特奇在他的传记中抓住不放的地方，也是理查德·达芬波特-海恩斯（Richard Davenport Hines）在最近为他写的一本简短传记草图中所描述的——把他描绘成一个令人毛骨悚然的怪人。戈登从未结婚。众所周知，他在面对女性时，
he's very awkward with women. Yeah. But he does devote himself when he is in charge of the artillery at Gravesend in Kent. He devotes a lot of his time to charitable works and particularly working with raggedy boys, boys who are starving, urchins. He lets them into his garden. He helps with their education. He provides places on ships. He follows their careers with great interest.
显得非常笨拙。是的。但是，当他在肯特郡格雷夫森德（Gravesend）负责炮兵工作时，他确实将大量时间奉献给了慈善事业，特别是与那些衣衫褴褛的男孩、挨饿的流浪儿打交道。他让他们进入自己的花园，帮助他们接受教育，为他们安排船上的工作，并以极大的兴趣关注他们的职业生涯。
And of course, this is seen as a work of great Christian philanthropy. But for Lytton Strachey and for Richard Davenport Hines, it's seen as something altogether more sinister and suspicious. And so that also is a part of the complexity of his reputation, isn't it? And on top of that, there is a kind of rumour that he was an alcoholic. So his life is very contested. And I think that everything that makes the Victorians contested is kind of summed up by his career. And you suggested this and I thought, I don't know about that. But having, I mean, honestly, it's a brilliant topic,
当然，这被视为一项伟大的基督教慈善工作。但在莱顿·斯特奇和理查德·达芬波特-海恩斯看来，这被认为是一件更加阴暗和可疑的事情。所以这也是他声誉复杂性的一部分，不是吗？除此之外，还有一种传闻说他是个酒鬼。因此，他的一生备受争议。我认为维多利亚时代所有充满争议的特质，都在他的职业生涯中得到了浓缩。你提出了这一点，而我想：“这我可不太清楚。”但仔细想想，老实说，这是一个极其精彩的主题，
and I completely commend you for it. Well, before we get into the sort of narrative of it, Tom, there's a bit of a Hall of Mirrors side of kind of Gordon's career, isn't there? Because if you read, there are lots of biographies. If you read three different biographies, they will give you three different, three subtly different accounts of his life and motivations. It's actually very hard to get to a true picture of gordon i think because
我完全赞赏你的选择。嗯，在我们进入他的故事叙述之前，汤姆，戈登的职业生涯其实有一点“镜厅”的镜像效果，对吧？因为如果你阅读——有很多传记，如果你读三本不同的传记，它们会对他的生平和动机给出三种微妙差异的解读。实际上，我认为很难还原一个真实的戈登，因为
it depends so much on what weight you put on different people's statements about him on statements of his own and it also i think so that you talk about lit and straight in eminent victorians i mean i think so much of that portrait of of Gordon is kind of self-projection actually and I think it you know as we'll see with the sort of the helping the poor boys you know a lot of your interpretation of Gordon is on what you're bringing you're bringing to the table I think in your expectations anyway well and I think that it it also and it may not surprise you to hear me say this i think it depends on how seriously you take gordon's christianity yeah and and whether you think that gordon's christianity is a kind of screen for predatory sexuality or all kinds of things or whether you think that he is sincere and yeah it's sincere yeah so we can perhaps discuss that
这很大程度上取决于你对不同人关于他的言论、以及他自己的言论赋予了多少权重。而且我认为——说到莱顿·斯特奇在《维多利亚时代名人传》中的描写，我认为对戈登的这种刻画，其实很大程度上是一种自我投射。正如我们稍后看到那些关于救助贫困男孩的事迹一样，我对戈登的大部分解读，其实取决于你带着怎样的期待、把你自己的想法带入了其中。不过，我也认为——如果你听到我这么说可能会觉得不吃惊——我认为这还取决于你对戈登的基督教信仰有多认真。
as we go as we go so we will build up um to the huge melodrama of the siege of khartoum and the fall of khartoum and the battle with the mardi and stuff but maybe we should go into him gordon and his career first to give people a sort of sense of the of the background so he's the son of a lieutenant colonel in the royal artillery he's born in 1833 in woolwich he's brought up in a part of his childhood tom in a place you know very well in corfu in corfu yeah yeah so he probably played cricket in corfu i imagine as you have well and he then he gets sent to um a school in taunton and the um the playing fields of this um school are now the cricket ground of somerset county cricket club oh that's always nice there's definitely a cricket link there and um gordon wasn't was a keen cricketer well i'm glad i'm glad for you that
是的，以及你认为戈登的基督教信仰是某种掠夺性性取向的掩护，还是其他各种事情，亦或是你认为他是真诚的？是的，他是真诚的。所以，随着我们的深入，我们可以讨论这一点。我们将逐步铺垫到喀土穆围城战的巨大情节剧、喀土穆的陷落以及与马赫迪的战斗等等，但也许我们应该先讲讲戈登和他的早期职业生涯，好让听众对背景有一个大致的了解。所以他是皇家炮兵中校的儿子，1833年出生于伍尔维奇（Woolwich）。汤姆，他童年的一部分时间是在你非常熟悉的一个地方度过的——在科孚岛，在科孚岛。
this has happened because i did suggest this and uh I know you were a little bit suspicious at first, but it's got Christianity and cricket. So basically I could have designed it. And Dominic. It's got eunuchs. Yes, it has. Because he made this fame, you know, talking about his boyhood. He was quite a naughty boy, wasn't he? He was a prankster.
所以他可能在科孚岛打过板球，我想，就像你一样。好吧，然后他被送到汤顿（Taunton）的一所学校上学，而这所学校的运动场现在成了萨默塞特郡板球俱乐部（Somerset County Cricket Club）的板球场。哦，那太棒了，那里绝对有板球的渊源。而且戈登曾经是个狂热的板球爱好者。嗯，我为你发生这样的巧合感到高兴，因为我确实提议了这个主题，而且我知道你一开始有点怀疑，但它既有基督教，又有板球。所以基本上这就是为我量身定制的。还有多米尼克，
He's a prankster. He goes to the Royal Military Academy in Woolwich. So he's ran thester he's a prankster he goes to the royal military academy um in woolwich so he's ran but the arsenal that gives its name to the football club um signs up to the royal engineers um but while he's there he he seems to have started to have kind of religious promptings yeah and he famously said later on in that that at the age of 14 i wished i were an eunuch yeah that's uh it's an unusual see i i get this is the first example i think of something that where it's very hard to know how to interpret that did he genuinely wish he were a eunuch is he making a remark about you know he was struggling with kind of what he would see as sinful, lascivious longings.
里面还有太监。是的，确实有。因为他曾因此出名，你知道的，说到他的童年，他曾经是个相当淘气的男孩，对吧？他是个恶作剧者。他是个人精。他去了伍尔维奇的皇家军事学院。所以他是个恶作剧者。他去了伍尔维奇的皇家军事学院，所以他是——不过，正是那个以其名字命名了这家足球俱乐部的兵工厂……他报名加入了皇家工兵部队。然而在那期间，他似乎开始产生某种宗教上的感悟。
You know, because obviously he's going through puberty at 14. What what what how much weight do you I mean, it's impossible to know, isn't it, Tom? Well, I think I think he clearly has kind of religious promptings that that they're they're not dominating his life at this point but they're clearly there and i would guess the likeliest explanation would be that he is feeling urges to do things that are against you know christian teaching whatever that is like you know having extramarital sex or whatever or yeah who knows gay sex i mean who knows um but then he gets uh he qualifies doesn't he and gets posted to uh to pembroke yeah um to to be an engineer at the docks and there he is born again he is he's born again i i seem to get
是的，他后来在晚年时有句名言：“在我14岁时，我曾希望自己是个太监。”是的，这……这很不寻常。你看，我认为这是我遇到的第一个例子：很难知道该如何解释这句话。他是真的希望自己是个太监吗？他是在说——你知道的，他当时正在与他认为是罪恶的、淫荡的渴望做斗争。
the impression he's born again multiple times in his, or he goes through periods of intense religious awakening. This is the first. He meets a man called Captain Drew, I think, who's an Irish Protestant who sort of seems to semi-convert him. And it's the Protestant quality of it that is key because it's this idea of the spirit descending, of Gordon feeling a sense of personal redemption. And in due course, he will have the sense that he's born into Christ. And I think everything about his life suggests he takes this completely seriously. Yeah. So when Little Strachey and Eminent Victorians portrayed him as a hypocrite and a charlatan, I think that is utterly, utterly wrong. everything about his life suggests he takes this completely seriously yeah so when little
你知道的，因为他显然在14岁时正经历青春期。你认为我们应该给它赋权多少……我的意思是，这根本无法得知，对吧，汤姆？好吧，我认为他显然有一些宗教感悟，它们在当时并没有主导他的生活，但它们确实存在。我猜最可能的解释是，他当时感到了去做违背基督教教义事情的冲动——无论那是什么，比如婚外性行为之类的，或者……谁知道呢，同性恋行为？谁知道呢……但随后他获得了资格，对吧，被派往了彭布罗克（Pembroke），
strachey and eminent victorians portrayed him as a hypocrite and a charlatan i think that is utterly utterly wrong because everything we know about gordon suggests that he is completely serious about this and it matters enormously this amazing um comment on him by by someone who knew him a friend that he is without the three strongest passions which make men good or bad, the love of money, the love of fame, and the love of women. And, you know, those are kind of amazing.
去当码头的工程师。正是在那里，他重获新生。他重生了。我似乎有一种印象，他在一生中经历过多次重生，或者说他经历了强烈宗教觉醒的时期。这是第一次。他遇到了一位叫德鲁（Drew）的船长，我想那是一个爱尔兰新教徒，似乎半信半疑地让他皈依了。其中新教的特质是关键，因为这是一种灵降的理念，是戈登感受到个人救赎的理念。随之而来的是，他会有一种自己融入基督的意识。我认为他生活中的一切都表明他对此极其认真。所以当莱顿·斯特奇在《维多利亚时代名人传》中把他描绘成一个伪君子和江湖骗子时，我认为那是彻头彻尾的错误。
You know, it will be a theme throughout his career that he is utterly contemptuous of money. And whenever he's offered the salary for, you know, as leading men in China or Sudan or wherever, he rejects it. And he shares the money out among people who need it more. as leading men in China or Sudan or wherever, he rejects it. And he shares the money out among people who need it more. The love of fame, I mean, again, this has a kind of,
因为我们对戈登的了解表明，他对此是完全认真的，而且这极其重要。一个熟悉他的人、他的朋友曾这样评价他：他身上没有那种使人变好或变坏的最强烈的激情——对金钱的爱、对名誉的爱以及对女人的爱。而且，你知道的，这些真是惊人的评价。
you might think that someone who ends up the most famous man in the world, this would be a ludicrous thing to say. But again, so when he's in the Sudan the first time, he has a kind of deputy who he sends out to go and find a lake so that he won't have the glory of winning it. And he gets, for his work on the frontier in Armenia, he gets elected a fellow of the Royal Geographical Society. And then he turns it down because he feels that this will raise his profile too high. So again, I think that you can see that this is a genuine instinct. And so the love of women, I mean, Lytton Strachey assumes that he's gay,
你知道，蔑视金钱将成为贯穿他职业生涯的一个主题。每当有人为他在中国、苏丹或其他地方担任领导职务提供薪水时，他都会拒绝。他把钱分给更需要的人。对于名誉的爱——我的意思是，这也带有一种……
which as you say, may well be a reflection more of Lytton Strachey who was gay than Gordon because it actually does seem that Gordon's shyness is around women. Yes, he's incredibly shy around women, except for his sister, who he... He's got an older sister, I think, that he confides in. But the attempt to control his sexual needs
你可能会认为，一个最终成为世界上最著名的人会觉得这很荒谬。但同样，当他第一次去苏丹时，他派了一位副手去寻找一个湖，这样他就不会独揽胜利的荣耀。为了他在亚美尼亚边境的工作，他被选为皇家地理学会会员，但他拒绝了，因为他觉得这会把他的知名度抬得太高。所以同样，你可以看出这是一种真正的本能。至于对女人的爱——我的意思是，莱顿·斯特奇假定他是同性恋，
are focused on women. Yeah, I think that's right. It's cod psychology, isn't it? I think it's pure speculation, the idea that he's gay. And it goes hand in hand with all this stuff about the boys, but just because you are kind to small boys and educate them and are charitable it doesn't mean that you necessarily have sinister motives we should say that he's kind to small girls as well and he's he's he's very kind to um to the elderly too yeah he's just an he's he is it's a really interesting thing
正如你所说，这可能更多地反映了同性恋身份的莱顿·斯特奇自己，而不是戈登，因为实际上戈登的害羞似乎是针对所有女性的。是的，他在女性面前极其害羞，除了他的姐姐——他有一个年长的姐姐，他可以向她倾诉。但他控制自己性需求的尝试，
because of course now our instincts when confronted with victorian philanthropy um the sort of the cultural sort of expectation now is that it will be exposed as mere hypocrisy and it's all a cover for something else but in gordon's case i think there's every reason to think it is absolutely heartfelt and genuine you know he doesn't do it for fame he doesn't do it for attention um the thing about his sort of sexuality that i think we can say is that he does have clearly some he's one of these people who has a sense of this is disgust too strong this this sense of revulsion from his own body he talks later on about how he hence about the eunuch thing how he thinks the body is a mere sheath for your soul uh that will be discarded later on and he has this is a kind of but this is theologically bred as well so again the question of whether so that's a heretical it's
都是围绕着女性展开的。是的，我想是的。这不过是廉价的心理学分析，对吧？我认为他是同性恋这种想法纯粹是猜测。它与所有关于那些男孩的传言如出一辙。但仅仅因为你对小男孩很好、教育他们并且热心慈善，并不意味着你一定有什么不可告人的险恶动机。我们应该指出，他对小女孩也很好，而且他对老人也非常好。是的，他就是这样一个人——这是一个非常有趣的事情，
kind of gnosticism isn't it it is it's verging on gnosticism the idea that the body itself is corrupt i mean that's not what conventional Christianity teaches. But he does hold to that because he's essentially self-educated as a Christian. And so he reads the Bible over and over again. I mean, he has an incredibly rich knowledge of scripture, but it leads him into kind of some faintly heterodox opinions. And so the question then is, well, does he arrive at the heterodox opinions because he's prompted by his sexuality to do that or vice versa? And I suppose we live in a post Freudian age where our instinct is always to assume that one's belief in scriptural theology is determined by one's sexuality. But I think that it's possible to overdo that. Yeah, I think what we can say though tom is that um when he
因为当然，现在当我们面对维多利亚时代的慈善事业时，我们的直觉和文化预期往往是：它会被揭露为仅仅是虚伪，是一切其他事情的遮羞布。但在戈登的例子中，我有充分的理由认为它是绝对发自内心且真诚的。你知道的，他这样做不是为了名誉，也不是为了博取关注。关于他的性取向，我认为我们可以说的是，他确实有某种明显的倾向——这种倾向与其说是厌恶，不如说是对他自己身体的一种反感。他后来谈到过——就像刚才提到的太监那件事一样——他认为身体不过是灵魂的一个剑鞘，
meets people particularly later in his life i mean they meet him and they're like oh you're chinese gordon you're the fellow who commanded the ever victorious army this great adventure and and then he just starts banging onto them about about um his kind of heretical ideas and lots of people at the time not just subsequently lots of kind of senior military people and administrators they think he's completely mad. Yeah. And this is one of the fascinating things about him, that even at the time people say, well, he's brilliant and he's a genius and he's incredibly brave and has complete integrity,
以后会被抛弃。这在神学上是有根源的。所以，这又回到了那个问题：这是一种异端邪说，有点类似于诺斯替教，对吧？是的，这近乎于诺斯替教，即认为身体本身是腐败的。我的意思是，这并不是传统基督教所教导的。但他确实坚持这一点，因为他基本上是一个自学成才的基督徒。因此，他一遍又一遍地读圣经。我的意思是，他对经文有着极其丰富的知识，但这确实将他引入了一些轻微的异端观点。所以问题就在于：他得出这些异端观点是因为他的性取向促使他这么做，还是反之亦然？我想我们生活在一个后弗洛伊德时代，我们的本能总是假设一个人对圣经神学的信仰是由他的性取向决定的。但我认为，这种说法可能有点过头了。
but he's also a lunatic. Well, or a saint. Yes. And so the margins between lunacy and saintliness, even in the Victorian period, are quite fine. So anyway, so that's a kind of general i guess kind of scan of of um gordon's psychology we've we've dealt with that in five minutes um but before we come to the break why don't we just um get him to china okay because it's in china
不过，汤姆，我认为我们可以说的是：当他与人见面时——尤其是在他晚年的时候——人们见到他会说：“哦，你是中国戈登，你是那个指挥过常胜军、经历过伟大冒险的家伙！”然后他就开始滔滔不绝地向他们灌输他的异端邪说。当时有很多人，不仅仅是后来的很多人——许多高级军官和行政官员都认为他完全是个疯子。
that he first becomes famous. So his first big thing is when he's in his early 20s, he gets sent to the Crimea. And there he makes a name for himself. He's very brave. He actually says later on, oh, I'd hoped to be killed when I was... I mean, it's hard to know how much this is true of him in the Crimea and the Crimean War.
这也是他迷人的地方之一，甚至在当时人们就说：“嗯，他又聪明又是天才，极其勇敢，有着绝对的正直，但他也是个疯子。”好吧，或者说是个圣人。是的。因此，即使在维多利亚时代，疯狂与圣洁之间的界限也是非常模糊的。无论如何，这可以说是对戈登心理的一个大致扫描——我们在五分钟内就处理完了这一切。但在我们进入休息时间之前，为什么我们不直接把他送去中国呢？因为正是在中国，
But again, and so Strachey kind of casts that as a death wish yeah but again you can see that as bread of his understanding of theology yeah because he thinks being it's the gateway to heaven yeah doesn't he so so garlett woolsey who he meets who's a um also in the crimean war young irishman who will go on to become um a very very eminent general and in fact the man who leads the expedition to become a very, very eminent general. And in fact, the man who leads the expedition to try and rescue Gordon in 1885. And he says that life to Gordon was but a pilgrim's progress between the years of early manhood
他第一次变得家喻户晓。所以他的第一件大事是，在他二十出头的时候，他被派往克里米亚。在那里，他崭露头角。他非常勇敢。他后来甚至说：“哦，我本来希望自己能死在……”我的意思是，很难知道他在克里米亚和克里米亚战争中的这些话有多少是真的。
and the heaven he now dwells in, the home he always longed for. So I think it's perfectly possible to see Gordon's bravery and his willingness to court death as an expression of his conviction that when he dies, he will be joined with the saviour. Yeah, I think that's fair enough. see Gordon's bravery and his willingness to court death as an expression of his conviction that when he dies, he will be joined with the saviour. Yeah, I think that's fair enough. So anyway,
但同样，斯特奇把这演绎成了一种求死的心态，但你也可以把它看作是他对神学理解的产物，因为他认为死亡是通往天堂的大门，不是吗？因此，他遇到的加内特·沃尔斯利（Garnet Wolseley）——也是一位参加过克里米亚战争的年轻爱尔兰人，后来成为了一名非常、非常卓越的将军，事实上，也就是在1885年率领远征军去营救戈登的人——他说，对戈登来说，从青年时代到他现在所居住的天堂、他一直渴望的家园，人生不过是一场天路历程。所以我认为完全可以这样看待戈登的勇敢以及他甘愿赴死的态度，这是他坚信自己死后将与救世主团聚的一种表现。是的，这倒也合情合理。
he goes to the Crimea and there he kind of does this. He's a great surveyor and a kind of engineer, basically. So he will kind of crawl out of the trench and crawl close to the Russian trenches and sketch their forts. And he's brilliant at that. I mean, he's a brilliant kind of sketcher of enemy positions and so on. Physically, he's a brilliant kind of sketcher of enemy positions and so on. Physically, he's not a kind of strapping person by any means. He's quite slight. He's great. He's quite nondescript,
无论如何，他去了克里米亚，并在那里大显身手。他是一个出色的勘测员和工程师。所以他会从战壕里爬出去，爬到俄罗斯战壕附近去绘制他们的堡垒。他在那方面简直棒极了。我的意思是，他是一个极其出色的敌方阵地绘图员等等。从体型上看，他绝对不是那种身强力壮的人。他相当瘦弱。他长得——他相当不起眼，
except for these, people talk about these piercing kind of grey-blue eyes and people are struck by them even at the time. In the Crimea, he picks up his one big vice, which is cigarette smoking. Yeah, I didn't realize that cigarettes... No, neither of us knew this, Tom. ...were introduced at the Crimean War.
除了那些——人们提到他那双锐利的灰蓝色眼睛，甚至在当时就给人们留下了深刻的印象。在克里米亚，他染上了他唯一的大烟瘾，那就是抽香烟。是的，我以前没意识到香烟……是的，我们俩都不知道这一点，汤姆。……是在克里米亚战争期间被引入的。
Yes, we've both learned something from doing this podcast. So yeah, the cigarette smoking became a big thing with the Crimean War. He becomes a complete addict. You know, he's a chain smoker. So he's distinguished himself in the Crimea as a surveyor and as a kind of engineer. And he's then sent to the Danube as a surveyor and as a kind of engineer. And he's then sent to the Danube as a surveyor to kind of help sketch out the frontier between the Ottoman and Russian empires, the new frontier at the end of the Crimean War.
是的，我们俩通过做这个播客都学到了一些东西。所以，是的，吸烟随着克里米亚战争成了一件大事。他彻底成瘾了。你知道的，他是个老烟枪。因此，他在克里米亚作为勘测员和工程师而脱颖而出。随后，他被派往多瑙河担任勘测员和工程师。接着，他被派往多瑙河担任勘测员，以帮助划定奥斯曼帝国与俄罗斯帝国之间的边境，即克里米亚战争结束时的新边境。
Then, as you say, he's sent to Armenia where he slides down Mount Ararat. Did you see that? Mount Ararat. And sort of slides down it. I mean, that perfectly captures the man, doesn't it? Because it's a combination of kind of religiosity and demented adventuring. But also Ararat is the mountain on which Noah's Ark is meant to have landed.
然后，如你所说，他被派往亚美尼亚，并在那里从亚拉腊山（Mount Ararat）上滑了下去。你看到那个了吗？亚拉腊山。就这么滑了下去。我的意思是，这完美地契合了这个人的性格，不是吗？因为这是宗教狂热与疯狂冒险的结合。而且亚拉腊山正是诺亚方舟据说登陆的山峰。
But Gordon doubts that. So this will also become a theme. He knows better. Yes, exactly. He's a great man for discovering biblical locations, isn't he? As we will find out. As we will find out. As we will find out. And then, so he has all these sort of adventures.
但戈登对此表示怀疑。所以这也将成为一个主题。他觉得自己更懂。是的，没错。他是一个擅长发现圣经记载地点的人，不是吗？正如我们将要发现的那样。正如我们将要发现的那样。正如我们将要发现的那样。然后，他经历了所有这些冒险。
He goes and meets Kurdish villagers and he goes to Tbilisi, the capital of Georgia and so on. And then in the autumn of 1860, he goes to China. And China is in the throes of the most extraordinary convulsion. Well, Dominic, let's take a quick break here. So, and when we come back, tell us what the great convulsion that's going on when Gordon arrives in China, what it is. We'll see you in a few minutes. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q& q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works
他去拜访库尔德村民，去了第比利斯（格鲁吉亚首都）等等。接着，在1860年秋天，他去了中国。而当时的中国正处于最不寻常的剧变之中。嗯，多米尼克，我们在这里稍作休息。等我们回来时，请告诉我们当戈登抵达中国时，那场席卷中国的大剧变究竟是什么。几分钟后见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐之巅》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料的每周必听节目。在问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com hello welcome back we are talking gordon of khartoum but before he became gordon of khartoum he was known as chinese gordon and dominic i interrupted you by going to a break um you were telling us what the convulsion was that uh china was afflicted by when he arrives so china is a bit of a basket case in the 19th century um it's involved in two different wars at once at this point one is the second opium war so basically the british and the french are trying to open up china and seize kind of treaty ports and so they can flog them drugs so they can yes we can we can sell the drugs. And that's going to culminate in the burning of the Winter Palace in Beijing, at which...
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及提前获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回来。我们正在谈论喀土穆的戈登，但在他成为喀土穆的戈登之前，他被称为“中国戈登”。多米尼克，我刚才打断了你并进入了休息时间——你刚才正要告诉我们，当他抵达中国时，中国正遭受着怎样的剧变。因此，19世纪的中国就像是一个烂摊子。它当时同时卷入了多场不同的战争：其中之一是第二次鸦片战争，基本上就是英国人和法国人正试图打开中国的大门并夺取一些通商口岸，以便他们可以向中国倾销毒品。为了我们可以——是的，我们可以售卖毒品。
That's 1858. In which Gordon is present, along with Sir Harry Flashman, who meets him at the end of the book, Flashman and the Dragon. Would you know, this whole way through, I've been thinking that Gordon is a kind of upstanding Flashman. He is. Because he goes everywhere, doesn't he? Yeah, he has that same kind of trajectory where he just keeps popping up in these strange places.
这将最终导致北京圆明园的焚毁。在那场事件中……那是1858年。戈登也在场，同行的还有大名鼎鼎的哈里·弗莱什曼爵士（Sir Harry Flashman），他在书的结尾《弗莱什曼与巨龙》（Flashman and the Dragon）中遇到了他。你知道吗，这一路听下来，我一直觉得戈登就像是一个品格高尚的弗莱什曼。他确实是。因为他无处不在，对吧？是的，他有着那种相同的轨迹，总是不停地在这些奇怪的地方冒出来。
But he very strongly disapproves of the burning of... He doesn't approve of it at all. And actually, in the flashman book, he's there as a sort of pale eyewitness. He just comes in briefly. But you're right. He doesn't really approve of this. And he disapproves of the French looting. Yeah, the looting, which is shocking.
但他对火烧圆明园的行为持非常强烈的反对态度。他一点也不赞同。实际上，在弗莱什曼的那本书里，他作为一名面色苍白的目击者出现在那里，只是短暂地露了一下面。但你说得对。他确实不赞同这种行为，并且也反对法国人的掠夺。是的，那种令人发指的掠夺。
Doesn't like looting. Yeah. So all these kind of things that people now hold against the British Empire. So the idea of looting stuff. You know, we hear a lot back with reference to British museums holding imperial loot. This isn't entirely a 21st century perspective. Gordon had that perspective as well. i mean snowflakes like gordon were complaining in there sorry to tell me you walked
他不喜欢掠夺。是的，所有这些现在被人们用来指责大英帝国的种种行为——比如掠夺文物的想法。我们经常听到关于英国博物馆收藏帝国掠夺文物的言论。这并不完全是21世纪的视角。戈登当时也有这种视角。我的意思是，像戈登这样的“左翼温和派”当时就在抱怨……抱歉，汤姆，你掉进我设的圈套里了。
into that one right um but that's not really the big story or extraordinary as it may seem the big story is the typing rebellion which is more your kind of thing tom because it's mad christianity it is do you want to tell us about the Taiping Rebellion? So the Taiping Rebellion is, I mean, carnage. A guy called Hong Siu Kwan, I hope I pronounced that. That was beautifully done. Some approximation to how it should be pronounced, essentially decides that he's the younger brother of Jesus. And for very complicated reasons that I would need to spend
不过，这并不是真正的大新闻。尽管听起来可能有些不可思议，但真正的大新闻是太平天国起义。这更像是你的菜，汤姆，因为那是疯狂的基督教。你想给我们讲讲太平天国起义吗？所以太平天国起义，我的意思是，那简直是一场血腥屠杀。一个叫洪秀全的人——希望我没有发错音。你发得很美妙。这跟正确的发音相当接近。他基本上认为自己是耶稣的弟弟。由于一些我需要花更多时间在博德利图书馆（Bodleian）研究的极其复杂的历史原因，整个中国基本上都陷入了疯狂并认同了他。被称为“太平军”的军队令清朝应接不暇——由于鸦片战争和普遍的怠政，太平天国起义是一场充满杀戮、骇人听闻且血腥的内战过程。但它同时也是一种类似宗教十字架远征的运动，对吧？
more time in the Bodleian studying, basically the whole of China goes insane and agrees with him. And the Taipings, as they're called, the Qing dynasty is absolutely up against it because of the Opium Wars and general kind of disitude. The Taiping Rebellion is a murderous, horrific, bloodthirsty process of civil war. But it's also a kind of religious crusade, isn't it? Kind of. And so a lot of people in Britain think that it's Protestantism coming to China. And so there's quite a lot of enthusiasm in Britain for the Taipings, despite the fact that they're basically murderous. Well, could you not see, Tom,
某种程度上是这样的。所以英国的很多人认为这是新教传到了中国。因此，尽管太平军基本上充满了杀戮，英国国内对他们还是有着相当高的热情。汤姆，难道你不觉得——
could you not see the Taiping Rebellion and the creation of the Mardist kind of state in Sudan? They're both places where Christianity and westernization and modernization and imperialism have arrived with a great shock in the kind of yeah mid-victorian period and kind of traditional structures have been splintered and these are ways of trying to to react well and and you know who pointed that out was actually strachey so little strachey drew the analogy between um hong shu kwan and and the mardi I'm disappointed to find that I'm in the same...
难道你不觉得太平天国起义与苏丹马赫迪式政权的建立之间有相似之处吗？它们都是基督教、西方化、现代化以及帝国主义以巨大冲击波的形式闯入中叶维多利亚时代、导致传统社会结构碎裂的产物，而这些运动正是人们试图对此做出反应的方式。而且，你知道是谁指出这一点的吗？实际上正是斯特奇。莱顿·斯特奇在洪秀全与马赫迪之间画了等号。我很失望地发现我和他竟然是同一类人……
They both began as religious reformers, ended as rebel kings. Right, well, I wouldn't have thought of us as similar people, but clearly little than I am. But specifically, the issue and why the British, and specifically Gordon, get sucked into it is that the Taipings are menacing Shanghai. Yeah, and the bankers and merchants there.
他们都是以宗教改革家开局，却以叛军国王收场。好吧，我可不认为我们是相似的人，但显然莱顿和我……不过具体来说，问题在于——以及为什么英国人、尤其是戈登会被卷入其中——是因为太平军正在威胁上海。是的，那里的银行家和商人。
European merchants. Basically raise their own little army, the ever-victorious army. Which is a great name for an army, isn't it? It makes it sound absolutely fantastic, but actually it's a really ragtag, shambolic band of kind of mercenaries and drunkards, and it's commanded by this American guy called Frederick Townsend Ward, who does seem to be quite, doesn't he? He wears a frock coat, and I think he's quite a dashing figure uh frederick tanzo ward he meets flashman and fleshman and the dragon um but he's killed
欧洲商人们基本上组建了他们自己的小军队——“常胜军”。这是一个军队的绝妙名字，不是吗？听起来绝对酷炫，但实际上它是一支由雇佣兵和酒鬼组成的乌合之众、一盘散沙般的队伍，由一个名叫弗雷德里克·汤森·沃德（Frederick Townsend Ward）的美国人指挥。他看起来确实挺有型，不是吗？他穿着 frock coat（长礼服大衣），我认为弗雷德里克·汤森·沃德是一个相当潇洒的人物。他在《弗莱什曼与巨龙》里遇到过弗莱什曼。但他被杀害了，
i think and his successor is a french-american adventurer called henry i don't know how to pronounce it bergwein bergevin i don't know anyway he's a complete drunkard um and so they boot him out the the sort of the bankrollers of the ever victorious army it's quite small it's only about 5 or 6 thousand people they boot him out mostly Chinese right yeah a lot of them not all Chinese but yes mostly Chinese
我想是的。他的继任者是一个法美混血的冒险家，名叫亨利——我不知道该怎么发音——布尔热万（Burgevin），我不知道。总之，他是个彻头彻尾的酒鬼，所以“常胜军”的那些金主们就把他给炒了。“常胜军”的规模其实很小，只有大约五六千人。他们把他炒了，里面大部分是中国人。对，是的，其中许多人并不是全部中国人，但确实大部分是中国人。
exactly they boot him out and they want somebody else to do it and basically they ask around who's around in China and the British give them Gordon. And it showed that the ever victorious army is probably better known than it should be in some ways because it's quite a small outfit. And the reason they the fact that they give them Gordon tells you it's not that important because Gordon has actually never led an army into battle before. I mean, he's an engineer and a surveyor artillery man isn't he yeah exactly so
没错，他们把他赶了出去，想要别人来干这活，基本上他们在中国的四处打听谁在附近，英国人就把戈登派了过去。这表明常胜军的名气可能比它实际的要大，因为这其实是一支很小的队伍。他们派戈登去这个事实说明这并不是什么大事，因为戈登之前其实从来没有指挥过军队作战。我的意思是，他是个工程师和测绘炮兵，对吧？对，完全如此，所以
he doesn't really know what he's doing but he turns out to be very good at it to be good at commanding well because because there are lots of um rivers and canals and all kinds of stuff and so an ability to draw maps yes which gordon's very good at and they're all sort of steaming up and down rivers and stuff like this but also he's very strict isn't he he's a complete disciplinarian he bans hard liquor and so on and he has his pay cut and he gives it to his troops but he has this extraordinary persona where he so he always goes into battle smoking a cheroot um and he carries a cane unarmed yeah he's exactly he doesn't he goes in unarmed he carries this cane doesn't he
他其实不知道自己在干什么，但事实证明他非常擅长指挥，因为那里有许多河流、运河和各种各样的地方，所以绘制地图的能力——是的，这是戈登非常擅长的——而且他们都在河里上下开着蒸汽船之类的，但同时他非常严格，对吧？他是个彻底的纪律严明者，他禁止烈性酒等等，他还减了自己的薪水并分给部下，但他有一种非凡的个人魅力，那就是他总是抽着雪茄上战场，而且他带着手杖，手无寸铁，是的，他完全是这样，他手无寸铁地上前，拿着这根手杖，对吧？
what do they call it his magic baton or something i can't remember what that was so again listen straight she who you know we've said is a bit of a bitch but actually um saying about gordon he seemed to pass through every danger with the scatheless equanimity of a demigod yeah it's a very impressive i mean this is very impressive stuff. It's very cool, isn't it? You know, at one point,
他们管这叫什么来着？他的魔法指挥棒还是什么的，我记不清了。所以再次听听，慈禧——你知道的，我们说过她有点刻薄，但实际上，关于戈登，他似乎以半神那种毫发无损的平和穿过了所有的危险。是的，这非常令人印象深刻，我是说这非常厉害。这真的很酷，对吧？你知道，在某个时刻，
the artillery men mutiny, cause he won't let them loot. And he just, he manages to kind of brazen that out. Which again, is a kind of something that happens throughout his career. Yeah. Is that,
炮兵哗变了，因为他不让他们抢劫。而他居然设法挺过了这一关。这再次体现了贯穿他整个职业生涯的一点。是的，那就是，
you know, he fixes those gleaming blue eyes and people just crumble. People are always, he's always going into situations where lots of armed men want to kill him and he turns up with his cigar and they and they all just sort of say his love of jesus because it all works his sort of sanctity his it is like a kind of protective kind of veil isn't it do you not think i mean people don't quite know what to
你知道，他用那双发光的蓝眼睛一瞪，人们就崩溃了。人们总是——他总是陷入许多全副武装的人想要杀他的境地，而他带着雪茄出现，他们所有人都只是说，是因为他对耶稣的爱，因为这管用，他那种神圣性，这就像是一种保护性的面纱，难道你不这么认为吗？人们不完全知道该如何
make of him and i think both both the chinese and and in due course um people in the sudan are stunned by his chastity as well so the sense of him as yeah i kind of you know a demigod is straight she's worth that this is someone who is very very unusual and has a kind of almost supernatural quality to him um and that combined with his military evident military talents means that basically within 18 months he's won an absolutely crushing victory yeah typings have all been booted out so the typings are defeated um by the imperial army um the sort of qing army plus the ever victorious army now i think the role of the ever victorious army is probably a bit inflated and that certainly chinese histories don't give the Qing army plus the ever-victorious army. Now, I think the role of the ever-victorious army
看待他，而且我认为无论是中国人在当时，还是后来的苏丹人，都被他的贞洁所震撼，这种感觉让他——是的，就像一个半神。慈禧觉得这是一个非常非常不寻常、几乎具有某种超自然特质的人，再加上他明显的军事才能，意味着基本上在18个月内，他赢得了绝对压倒性的胜利。是的，太平军都被赶跑了，太平军被清军加上常胜军击败了。现在我认为常胜军的作用可能被高估了一点，而且可以肯定的是，中国史书并没有给予清军加上常胜军。现在，我认为常胜军的作用
is probably a bit inflated, and that certainly Chinese histories don't give it as much weight by any means. Well, but isn't that partly because the Taipings are seen as precursors of the communists? That's right, Tom. That's right. But actually, when you look at the numbers involved, there are hundreds of thousands of men
可能被高估了一点，而且中国的历史书肯定没有给予它那么重的分量。嗯，但这难道不是部分因为太平军被视为共产主义者的先驱吗？没错，汤姆。没错。但实际上，当你看到涉及的人数时，有成百上千的人
in various armies in the field. It's implausible that Gordon's little band is a single decisive factor but i do think that he gets this this incredible distinction yes the yellow jacket uh which is only 20 mandarins in the whole of the empire have it yeah and gordon gets given it so the order of the garter isn't it it's the order of the garter of china basically yeah and i think he's the Order of the Garter, isn't it? It's the Order of the Garter of China, basically. Yeah. And I think he's the only non-Chinese person to have it. Yeah. And so I think that that is, you know,
在战场上的各个军队中。戈登的小分队是唯一的决定性因素，这不太可能，但我确实认为他获得了无上的荣誉——是的，黄马褂，整个帝国只有20个文武官员拥有它。是的，戈登被授予了它。这就像是嘉德勋章，对吧？这基本上就是中国的嘉德勋章。是的。而且我认为他是获得此殊荣的唯一非中国人。是的。所以我觉得，你知道，
one can take the revisionism too far. Maybe. He was clearly seen by the Chinese themselves as incredibly impressive. And so he's, what, 30 by this point? Yeah, he's about 30, isn't he? And so he's been given this incredible award by the Chinese emperor. He's commanded an army and then he has to go back to England.
人们对历史的修正主义有点过头了。也许吧。他显然被中国人自己视为极其了不起的人。所以此时他多大了？对，他大约30岁，对吧？因此他被中国皇帝授予了这个不可思议的奖项。他指挥了一支军队，然后他不得不回到英国。
And he's unbelievably famous and he hates it. He hates the fame. He hates the celebrity. And what happens to him? He spends the next six years basically repairing forts in Gravesend. And helping out raggedy boys and pensioners. So he sent to Gravesend, which obviously had always been, because of its importance, sort of naval, sort of coastal importance,
他红得发紫，但他讨厌这样。他讨厌名气。他讨厌名人身份。他后来怎么样了？在接下来的六年里，他基本上是在格雷夫森德修理堡垒，并帮助那些衣衫褴褛的男孩和养老金领取者。所以他被派往格雷夫森德，由于其重要性，这里历来是某种海军、某种海岸重要防线，
had always been very heavily defended. And they basically say to him, go and sort out these forts and modernise the defences and stuff. But he knows as well as everybody else, they're never going to be used else they're never going to be used it's a complete waste of his time um i think they so he gets up early doesn't he has a cold shower yeah then he goes out and does good reads the bible um goes and supervises the fort and then he spends all his afternoons doing good yes and clearly he's a bit the must that there clearly is some point at which he's feeling a bit miserable, that fate has turned against him and doesn't know what to do with himself.
一直以来都有着极其坚固的防御。他们基本上对他说，去把这些堡垒整顿一下，把防御设施现代化什么的。但他和所有人一样清楚，这些防御设施永远不会派上用场。这完全是在浪费他的时间。所以他起得很早，对吧？洗个冷水澡，然后出去做好事，读《圣经》，去监督堡垒，然后他整个下午都在做好事。是的，很明显他有点——显然在某一点上他觉得有点痛苦，命运背弃了他，不知道该拿自己怎么办。
But then he goes to a dinner party. Do you see this? He goes to a dinner party in Greenwich. And as luck would have it, while he's dressing for dinner, his gaze falls on the open pages of the Bible. So he's a man who reads the Bible while dressing for dinner, basically. And he sees the first epistle of St. John,
但随后他去参加了一个晚宴。你看到了吗？他去格林威治参加了一个晚宴。阴差阳错的是，当他正为晚宴换衣服时，他的目光落在了翻开的《圣经》书页上。所以他基本上是一个在换晚宴服时读《圣经》的人。他看到了《约翰一书》，
whosoever shall confess that Jesus is the Son of God, God dwelleth in him and he in God. And on seeing this, he's kind of a man transformed. He says, gosh, all I need to do is believe in Jesus as the Son of God. I mean, it's a real evangelicalism, isn't it and it's from that that his feeling philanthropical yeah exercises proceed and he becomes very excited about the philanthropy so in gravesend he sets up this little sort of it's almost like a school isn't it they have they meet twice a week um he teaches all the boys
“凡认耶稣为神儿子的，神就住在他里面，他也住在神里面。”看到这个，他整个人都变了。他说，天哪，我所需要做的就是相信耶稣是神的儿子。我的意思是，这是一种真正的福音派信仰，对吧？正是从这种信仰出发，他的慈善行为才得以展开，他对慈善事业变得非常狂热。所以在格雷夫森德，他建立了一个这样的小型——这几乎就像一所学校，对吧？他们一周见面两次，他教所有的男孩
wangs yeah now that might sound again may uh they raise eyebrows but he calls them boys wangs. Yeah. Now, that might sound... Again, may raise eyebrows. He calls them his wang because in China, a general or a chief was called, a warlord was called a wang. And so he had wangs in his ever-victorious army. So that could be misinterpreted. And the boys, obviously, you can imagine the boys probably think it's hilarious and brilliant that they've been called wangs. And they do have prayers.
王（Wangs），是的。现在听起来可能——可能会让人侧目，但他叫他们“王（Wangs）”。是的。现在，这听起来……再次可能会让人侧目。他管他们叫他的“王”，因为在中国，一个将军或首领被称为——一个军阀被称为“王”。因此他在他的常胜军里也有“王”。所以这可能会被误解。而这些男孩们，显然，你可以想象男孩们可能觉得被叫作“王”是极其搞笑和精彩的。他们确实有祷告。
They sing hymns. He gives them bread and soup and stuff, and they do their lessons. And then he places them in work. In ships, doesn't he? In ships. So there'll be a ships boy and all this. And he has a big map, as you said at the beginning of the episode. He has this big map as you said at the beginning of the of the episode he has this big map and um every night you know he and his his wangs gather around and they he
他们唱赞美诗。他给他们面包和汤之类的东西，他们上课。然后他帮他们安排工作。在船上，对吧？在船上。所以会有一个船童之类的。正如你在节目开始时所说的那样，他有一张大地图。正如你在节目开始时所说的那样，他有一张大地图，而且每天晚上，你知道，他和他的“王”们聚集在一起，他
gets one of them to to chart where the other boys you know the old boys are on the map i mean i think that's all actually pretty sweet and well i think you've got to take you know do you take this being born again this this sense that god's grace has come upon him seriously or do you not well and in in in in um john is it john pollock yeah john pollock's book gordon the man behind the legend a very kind of admiring biography of gordon he has quite a lot of quotes from the old boys of the Gordon Academy. Yeah. Ex-Wangs who basically say, Gordon changed my life.
让其中一个在地图上标出其他男孩——你知道，老男孩们——现在在哪里。我的意思是，我觉得这一切其实挺温馨的。好吧，我觉得你必须认真对待这种重生——这种上帝的恩典降临在他身上的感觉，还是不呢？好吧，在约翰——是约翰·波洛克吗？对，约翰·波洛克的书《戈登：传奇背后的男人》，一本对戈登非常赞赏的传记中，他引用了许多戈登学院老男孩的话。是的。前“王”们基本上说，戈登改变了我的人生。
You know, I owe him everything. It was wonderful. He was such a great man. You know, all this sort of stuff. So... I mean, he's not Jimmy Savile. Let's put it that way. Well, there's...
你知道，我的一切都归功于他。太棒了。他是个如此伟大的人。你知道，所有这些类似的话。所以……我的意思是，他可不是吉米·萨维尔。我们这么说吧。好吧，有……
Actually, the week that this is going out, so I think... I can't remember whether it's on the day of his birth, 28th of January, or his death, 26th of January. But there's a ceremony at Gravesend in front of the statue of him there. So he's still remembered there. That's nice. Yeah, it is nice, I think.
实际上，就在这期节目播出的这一周，所以我想……我不记得是在他出生的日子1月28日，还是他去世的日子1月26日。但在格雷夫森德他的雕像前会举行一个仪式。所以人们在那里依然纪念他。那挺好的。是的，确实挺好的，我想。
Anyway, so we're not being cynical about it. No, I'm definitely not cynical about Gordon. I think Gordon is, at this point, you would say... A Christian hero. Well, the philanthropy is incredibly impressive, I think. I mean, I wouldn't do it myself. Because, of course not. I'm far too selfish and lazy.
总之，所以我们并不是对此持冷嘲热讽的态度。不，我绝对不是在讽刺戈登。我觉得此时的戈登，你会说……一个基督教英雄。好吧，我认为这种慈善事业令人印象深刻。我的意思是，我自己可做不到。因为，当然不会。我太自私也太懒了。
Of course, you keep the money. But he's being paid quite a lot and he gives it all away. Yeah. As he does throughout his entire life. Do you know what, Dominic? We've spent 40 minutes. We haven't got very far. Well, so Gordon's great phrase, inaction is terrible to me.
当然，你得留着钱。但他拿了相当多的薪水，却全捐出去了。是的。就像他一生中一直做的那样。你知道吗，多米尼克？我们花了40分钟了。我们没聊出多远。好吧，所以戈登的名言是：无所作为对我来说太可怕了。
So he's been to China. He's been in Grove's End. He's hanging out with the Wangs. Now comes the point where he goes to the country that will really make him famous, which is the Sudan. And so tomorrow we'll come back and we will talk about Gordon's career in the Sudan, the two times that he goes to that country.
所以他去过中国。他去过格雷夫森德。他和“王”们混在一起。现在到了他前往那个真正让他成名的国家的时候了，那就是苏丹。所以明天我们会回来，谈谈戈登在苏丹的职业生涯，他两次前往那个国家的经历。
If, however, you are a member of the Wrestling History Club, you don't need to wait because you can listen to the whole thing today. Incredible value. So we will see you in 30 seconds if you're a member of the Restless History Club
然而，如果你是“历史其余部分”俱乐部的会员，你不需要等待，因为你今天就可以听完整期节目。超值的体验。所以如果你是“历史其余部分”俱乐部的会员，我们30秒后见，
and we'll see you tomorrow if you're not. We should call them our wangs. I like that. If you're a wang, you can carry on listening. If not, too bad. Bye-bye.
如果你不是，我们明天见。我们应该把我们的听众也叫作“王”。我喜欢这样。如果你是个“王”，你可以继续听。如果不是，那就太糟了。再见。
Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。想要获取独家节目、抢先收听、无广告体验以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。